President Trump will speak to the nation
tonight to unveil the next step for the
u.s. in its longest war ever Afghanistan
the move is likely to require more
American troops the president has his
family returned to the White House last
night after his 17 day working vacation
in New Jersey mr. Trump and his national
security team met on Friday to decide on
a new military strategy and Margaret
Brennan is at the White House this
morning with the latest good morning
good morning well president Trump's
decision has been delayed for months by
concerns that the us-led coalition and
Afghan military are not winning the war
against the Taliban al Qaeda and Isis
now tonight we will hear the president
unveil his path forward for the longest
war in American history the president is
expected to greenlight the deployment of
around 4,000 additional US troops to
Afghanistan and put new pressure on
nearby Pakistan to stop giving safe
haven to terrorists the strategic
process was sufficiently rigorous and
did not go in with a preset condition in
terms of what questions could be asked
or what decisions would be made
defense secretary Jim mattis said Sunday
that US troop numbers may fluctuate
adding to the more than eight thousand
forces already in the country I want to
find out why we've been there for 17
years President Trump has questioned
whether to pull out of Afghanistan which
the Obama administration had once
advocated Virginia senator Tim Kaine the
real question is what is our strategy
and then when you lay out the strategy
then the troop strength question can
kind of answer itself in search of a new
approach now former chief strategist
Steve Bannon had urged mr. Trump to send
paid mercenaries instead of troops an
idea that appeared to die with bannon's
Friday ouster mr. banek came on very
late you know that sources tell CBS News
that the president was frustrated by
descriptions of Bannon as his political
mastermind a self-described nationalist
Bannon saw himself as part of a new
political order every day
every day it is going to be a fight
within hours of his firing ban and
rejoined Breitbart news and declared war
on the opposition he told the Weekly
Standard quote the trump presidency that
we fought for and won is over now there
are several possibilities into
pressuring Pakistan to step up the fight
including cutting aid or even labeling
it a state sponsor of terrorism bill
officials do caution that until
President Trump makes this announcement
himself the plans could still be altered
Margaret Brennan thanks to you of course
CBS will bring you full coverage of the
president's remarks on Afghanistan it
begins at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central
right here on CBS Gail